welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if Westworld
season 3 left you feeling like Ciroc or
the man in black then this is the video
for you the season finale contained two
post-credit scenes and throughout this
video we'll be breaking down what they
actually mean we've already touched upon
this in our prior video however there's
a ton of more details that I definitely
think are worth going over there will of
course be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
episode then it's time to take yourself
offline and exit out the video don't
forget to subscribe to the channel for
content like this every day and please
drop a thumbs up if you enjoyed the
video without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown Westworld season 3 is ending
okay so Westworld season three ended
with Dolores uploading solomon's admin
powers into Rehoboam which then granted
access to Caleb who was able to shut the
Machine down this once more gave
humanity a choice and together he and
Maeve headed out into LA to watch the
world collapse in a scene that was very
very similar to the ending of Fight Club
elsewhere Bernard headed into the
sublime to find out what to do after the
end of the world and it did leave a lot
of things open-ended including the fate
of William who was heading to Dallas to
destroy the hosts that's where we pick
up in our first post-credit scene we
watch is William enters the Dallas
International Building in Dubai
I love how when he walks past two women
he says do you know what they make in
there and it's hilarious how he's acting
like he owns the place and he even
shoots a security guard before venturing
to the research department which is
where the hosts are made now I have seen
some people theorizing that this bit
takes place in the future but personally
I believe it happens almost immediately
after the events of the third season the
main reason that this theory came up is
because Williams assets were frozen and
Dubai is a long way from San Francisco
however he did meet with the banker who
and froze them after confirming that he
was still alive so rack had the
character declared dead before wanting
to send him off for the deep sleep with
the rest of the outliers but this was
halted and Eureka you can meet with the
banker and once more gay access plus
there's dried blood beside his mouth so
it's unlikely that this scene takes
place much long after
add that to the hail healing and the
yada yada yada
look mate it's a stupid theory and
that's coming from the guy who's famous
for stupid theories now upon reaching
the house making department William
comes face to face with Hale who is
almost healed
except for her arm we did see a hint of
her last week in which the side of a
face could be made out and it was badly
damaged william state said he thought
hosts could heal themselves but clearly
he doesn't know the wreck that she was
and it's likely taken hours for her just
to get to this point in shows when a
character is healing they often hint and
the damage being repaired and I think
this almost left in place to let us know
that she is healing herself so that when
she returns fully healed for the fourth
season it's not too jarring
hey loris congratulates him and says
that you right on time
implying that it was always part of a
plan to supplant the character
throughout season three Dolores has
slowly been replacing real world figures
with hosts and we saw this of course in
Hale Connells the Yakuza boss and the
SFPD officer Lawrence she too has done
this with William and out comes a copy
of him donning his classic Westworld
getup
she knew that William was planning to
destroy all hosts and this would
interfere with her plans enough she
created a duplicate that can take over
his business activities within the
company host William shows that he knows
everything that the real one will say
and do through saying his thoughts in
tandem with him he then slit his throat
and I don't know if it's just me but
Hale looked a bit sad and this may be
because she knew she was killing a man
that at one point meant a lot to her at
least when she was Dolores it Google
gets a bit confusing anyway I love how
in the episode may have said to Dolores
that she was trying to make another
William and she literally did this at
the end in the series most notably James
tell us copying someone always failed
because humans were too complicated
however the two hosts stay that William
is relatively simple and easy to predict
so we can guess that because Williams a
cruel and basic man is easier to
duplicate this too was given that
service by Ford who when he met William
in season two told him that he was a
pretty basic liam Dempsey jr. type guy
those were his exact words but William
wasn't too happy that he was a Titan of
industry that was pretty simple when it
all boil
down to it so that's how she's copied
him when others have failed we then see
that the two are building an army of
hosts and it's likely that they are
filling these with the de are collected
by Delos in Westworld hail made a copy
of this when serac told her to wipe it
and she will now be able to replace a
large portion of humanity I'm guessing
that at some point the plan was always
to do this as we did see that Musashi
had barrels full of host liquid but
perhaps Dolores had a change of heart
due to her interactions with Caleb hey
loris has not had this with the
character and thus she still hates
humanity Dolores is such a rebel that
even copies of her are going against the
Loras and she's clearly going against
the intended plan because she believes
that Dolores was just using her as a
pawn
so basically hail now has an army of
hosts that are all ready to take over
humanity and there will clearly be a
human verse hosts battle at some point
but who will humanity's army be well you
may remember that in episode 7 Caleb and
Dolores stumbled across a bunch of
frozen outliers which so racket removed
from society I believe that these will
be the forces that the humans used to
take on the machines and I see on me
will come into his own as he was capable
of building Rehoboam whereas serac
seemed pretty helpless in its collapse
always back up your work as for Williams
fate personally I don't believe that
he's dead and it's possible that we have
seen his hosts copy before at the end of
season 2 there was a post-credits scene
in which a version of William stumbled
into the forge to find it in runes
clearly some time had passed and not too
long after the episodes release
sharona's Lisa join Jonathan Nolan
cleared up its meanings stating that it
was long after the world had ended
Williams seemingly came across a host
copy of his daughter who said that he
had been through the park and mission
several times and that they'd been
testing for fidelity with the knowledge
that we have now it seems like this
William was the copy and that the host
version will always return to the place
that the real William went to after
killing his daughter
Williams host itself was operating in
its own loop constantly trying to get
beyond the death of his daughter which
was the one act that defined the real
ones life he wished to find out if he
was real or not and clearly the host is
carried across the originals existential
crisis if this is of course the host
William it may be that the real one
survived
but after being faced with the
vation of himself he now struggles even
more with his own reality now because we
know that William ends up in a dusty and
dank future it explains why Bernard ends
up looking like he's been antiqued
shoutouts everyone who remembers jackass
the last time we saw him he was peering
into the sublime while stubs bled out
into the bathtub but as we know from
Maeve's trip to war world time inside a
simulation moves differently to how it
does in the real world it looks like he
finally has an answer on what to do once
the world has ended but clearly Dolores
wanted him to visit the sublime for a
reason however it could just be that
this was carried out by Dolores to hide
him until the world ended and she may
have deliberately set the time delay in
order to protect him either way it's
likely that this was an order to sink
Bernard up with William and is possible
at season 4 could be dealing with two
timelines similar to the prior entries
we may see how the end of the world
plays out through the eyes of Caleb and
Maeve whilst we see the repercussions of
it on the other side through William and
Bernard this season sort of put
everything back on track and tightened
up how convoluted everything was I think
this was purposely put in place so that
we can go ahead in this new direction
without too many things getting in the
way now before we get into the theory
under Loras and I just wanna let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 part 1 box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
being with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the updates in
the comment section below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 15th of May and the set
will be shipped out from the end whoever
gets the prize it's the best of luck
that everyone who takes part ok so
season 3 seemingly ends with Dolores is
death however I don't think that it's
gonna be the last that we'll see up here
not only is her coda Musashi's head but
it also exists within lawrence inhale -
basically if you put any of their pills
inside a Dolores looking host then I
doubt many would be able to tell the
difference well maybe hail but but she's
a bit crazy but you get what I mean
other than the experience with Caleb
they have the same backstory and at
least there are other versions of her
out there we learned in the episode that
all of the hosts are copies of Dolores
in some ways so a thing that all of them
will have an aspect of her
and thus it's really hard to kill her
she's died thousands of times in the
show so there's no reason that she can't
come back though we haven't had anything
official just yet
I do believe that she will be returning
at some point as let's be honest Dolores
is the heart of the show now obviously
I'd loved hear your thoughts on the
post-credits scene as I'm sure they'll
be a lot of different theories make sure
you comment below and let me know and if
you enjoy this video then please give it
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full finale breakdown which is gonna
be linked at the end you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and there's a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]